Ha. You know, you have to think
about all these things. I mean,
I do think since Trump got elected,
conspiracy theorist had been
demonized and nobody talks about that.
There's a little bit, well,
I was always going on.
It was even before that there were
being demonized. But yeah, for sure.
Everybody's worried about the
other groups, which is fair.
I get that there's the people in the
cages. No good. I'm not for any of that.
People in the cage, they will. The kids in
the cages is not good. What do you mean?
The family separation. Oh,
water. All the cores. Real stuff.
But I think that people think that
conspiracy theories got Trump elected,
so now it's cool to hate conspiracy
theorists or people that are like,
let's take another look at this.
There's so many factors that got Trump
elected and it's a perfect storm of
people getting, getting fed up
with political correctness. Yeah.
Someone coming along that's
not a politician. You know,
the system is so rigged that after
a while you just like Jesus Christ.
How many more of these fake puppets
were going to put an office? There's,
I say this to comics,
I'm like,
everybody's done a show where everybody
goes at and bombs with their material
and then one guy gets up and just goes,
fuck this and screams and
yells and destroys because
that's what the room wanted
the whole night.
They wanted somebody to come up and just
realize how fucked everything was and
how nobody was having a good time.
And that's kind of what Trump was.
Trump was the guy that came
out and just riffed. Yeah,
he went out there with no material.
He just went out there and rift and
he went and, and I, when I heard,
and I'm sure you've seen this speech where
he talks about Ben Carson going after
his mother with a hammer and
trying to stab his friend.
This was one of the funniest things.
He was speaking and he was given a
stump speech. I don't know where it was.
I think it was, wasn't in Iowa,
but he was referencing Iowa.
And he's talking about Ben Carson's
book and that Ben Carson had admitted to
going after his mother with a hammer
and trying to stab his friend with an,
I mean, these are, these are in
that and Trump is talking about it.
Me and my friend would driving, uh, at in
New York City. We were laughing so hard.
I said this guys, I said,
he's going to win. I said,
I'll tell you why he's going to win.
I cannot stop watching this.
I can't,
I am so fixated by the idea that there's
a guy like this on the national stage
and he sang whatever he wants.
There was something intoxicating about
that in a lot of the things you were
saying were horrible,
but he was saying them.
And then on the other side you had Hillary
Clinton who was just a scripted oh,
careful person. And I'm like, you,
it's just boring to me.
I'm like,
sometimes he entertaining person wins
because you can't take your eyes off them.
Well, in this case for sure, I mean in
the, that it was a perfect, you know,
polar opposite between him
and her. Yeah. You know, no,
no experience versus vast
amounts of experience.
No real experience in the real world
versus vast amount of experiences.
Yeah. I mean there was a lot going on
between the two of them. It was a, it was,
it's,
it's a bad way to choose very old runs
really is very bad to look at candidates
and go, who's the most
entertaining? Yeah. Well,
it's also a bad idea to have one person,
right? It's a bad idea to have this,
this same system that was in place
back when there was fucking, you know,
a thousand people here. But I
think we've really dealt, like,
we have one person that seems
like we have one figurehead,
but we have kind of this permanent
political class of people. Yeah.
A nexus of powerful institutions
where you have career politicians,
career diplomats,
career military service people
that kind of don't leave.
So I think that's one of the reasons
that we haven't changed the system is
because one person
can't ever do that much.
Even though Trump is wild and crazy
and he's done a lot of bad things,
I don't think he would be allowed to
deviate from many of the policies like
that.
His predecessors had kind of established,
I think that like the American government,
and that's why this determine
like the deep state,
which a lot of people ridicule. It's
an undeniably true thing. I mean,
our policies are not just one guy gets
into office and he goes, here's how it is.
Right? I mean, it's the
result of a lot of, you know,
private corporations lobbying,
forming,
all kinds of forming an agenda and
a non democratic way. You know,
they're not accountable at a lot of these,
you know,
people that work at the CIA or the FBI
or the NSA, a lot of them are appointed.
They're not elected. Right. We
have no oversight. Um, we have,
I think it's 22 intelligence agencies now.
It's only that money.
I mean, it's something absurd.
How many could you name FBI, CIA,
NSA? Uh, probably DEA,
DEA, and intelligence.
I wouldn't say it's an intelligence
that they probably have intelligence
capabilities. I would
imagine FBI, CIA, Nsa, uh,
there's one in yet the dia,
director of intelligence,
the Pentagon. I mean, I don't know if
that's an entire agency, but I think it,
I mean I think it has the capabilities,
but we have all of these different,
I don't know if it's 22,
but it's a lot and they're all competing
with each other competing because they
all want money. They will
want budget. They all want,
and that's the thing that people
talking about the deep state.
It's like look at them all. Yeah. Look
at these guys. Here they are. Jesus.
Here are all the people that
are listening. Excited. Yeah.
The fucking space troops that we have
space through force that's going to be
good. And why not? Why not a space
for us? We'll eventually, right.
Eventually you're going to
have to have it. Oh yeah.
So why not have it now we have,
I don't know what the national
geospatial intelligence thing does.
They can't be any more relevant.
That's based force. Click on that one.
National Geospatial Intelligence Agency.
Be any less important
than the space force.
That's who the fuck knows how many
people were working on employs sixteen
thousand sixteen thousand look at that.
Look at their motto.
Scroll down a little bit. Scroll
down. No earth show the way.
Understand the world what founded in
[inaudible] 96 yeah, Clinton probably did.
It's probably where he keeps his
chicks. I mean this, right, but this is,
this is what I mean. Like what the hell
are these people doing now? What is it?
16,000 employees with their
motto? No, the earth show the way.
Understand the world. That sounds like a
year, like on a yoga studios, you know?
I mean it's absurd, but they get
billions of dollars to do whatever.
Then put that back up there with the
description. Look at it. We're good.
It says there,
it's a,
it's under the United States Department
of Defense and Intelligence Agency of
the United States intelligence community
with the primary mission of collecting,
analyzing and distributing geo spatial
intelligence in support of national
security. Which is why,
what does that mean?
What the Hell is geospatial intelligence?
I mean, this is what I mean.
This is insane. And if any, if you
ask a question, if you go, well,
what do these guys do? People yell
at you and they know you're there.
You're a conspiracy theorist
and you don't know this.
I just want to know what
geospatial intelligence is.
It's probably something simple and
now I'm going to look like an idiot.
It says it's intelligence about the
human activity on earth derive from the
exploitation and analysis of imagery and
geospatial information that describes
assesses and visually depicts physical
features and geographically referenced
activities on the Earth.
I mean this is,
I think that's how we
would know like that.
North Korea has a box size satellites,
satellite imagery I guess. Well,
there's probably a satellite agency too.
I think we've uncovered a scam.
I think we've uncovered a pretend agency
that nobody in that there's a guy right
now panicked in the tape of spatial
16,000 other employees going, shit,
we're going to have to find a real job.
We would study and shipping docs
from space. Yeah, we just got out. It
just got outbid on rogue and
is completely aw shucks mercy.
Not really there. That was an
actress, 100%. That's an actress.
But this is what I mean. If you,
if you look into this stuff,
it starts to get crazy. The amount
of people that are doing things,
we have no idea what
they're doing. I mean, 10,
I just did a private Gig at the Bethesda
country club in Maryland. Okay. It's,
you know, I'm still doing it. Private
gigs. Sadly. He got it. You know,
it has got to do what you gotta do.
I gotta do what you gotta do.
I go to the Bethesda
country called Maryland. Um,
it's the entire 10 counties
around Washington DC are
the wealthiest counties in
the world. I mean, in our country, they,
and it's not because you're selling
crab cakes, you know what I mean?
It's all defense industry,
Raytheon, uh, you know,
DynCorp things you've never heard of.
And they're old and they were,
it was a good gig. They were funny. I
got up and I was like, what do we, oh,
we a carving up Venezuela.
They all laughed. We're all
clapping. They're in new it,
you know, they liked it. They some
people get, and I was, like I said,
last week I did a fundraiser
for human trafficking victims.
This week I'm with the traffickers. You
guys a lot more fun and they're clapping.
They're clicked, they love it. They're
leaning in to being, that's good.
They're, you know, they're
morally compromise. Well,
there also hired a comedian to fuck with
them. Yes, that's a good point. I mean,
they expected, it's not like I came
out of nowhere. Well, you know, I mean,
it's like, so that's the
thing. It's like Trump bad,
but I don't know what the geospatial
people are till I don't have to,
I don't want to throw my hat in
with geospatial intelligence. Yeah.
I don't know what that means. I
mean, maybe we need it, you know?
But listen again to standup comedians
talking about what the world needs.
Great. It's fucking terrible,
right? I mean, I've been,
I've been trying to stress this more than
ever because of the fact that I have a
microphone. Right. And
people are listening. Don't
fucking pay attention to me.
Okay. I am not right. Well, the
best thing is, listen, you know,
you don't know you might be right,
right. But I'm definitely not an expert.
The best thing is if you go on Twitter
and a comedian will tweet something
really, you know, it's like we're
living in fascism and again,
like 400,000 likes and then the next
tweet, have you ever seen this tickle?
And while you guys are here,
check out my web series
and you'd go, are we, are we living in
fat? If we're living in fascism, you too.
I have a web series.
You can't have a web series.
And do I have the time to
luxuriate in your web series?
Or should I start arming
myself to over throw the gun?
What should I, what should I look at my
phone? I'm like, which way should I go?
But that's all they do. They go by, by the
way, while you're here, I have a patrion.
We're doing a project.
I'd like you to throw a few bucks there,
but we're living in
fascists. I mean, you know.